we I think hope that's now with these
new measures we can get on top of
whatever is out there very quickly we
hope that it is something that we will
now be able to ensure is put behind us
as a city I'm very very concerned
obviously about the impact on the
well-being of the city in general and
the health of the people in the city but
also about the economy of the city and
one of the things we've been stressing
to the government's over recent times is
that if Lester is to be locked down and
its economy in foot on in limbo for a
little longer we will need the support
that his given was given earlier in the
pandemic throughout the UK restored here
in Leicester and maintained here in
Leicester so that our economy doesn't
suffer from what is happening to the
health of our people but we are
determined now to to use this
opportunity to to work effectively with
the measures of the governor's given
that now I hope with the support the
government is going to be giving to us
to make sure this is something we can
deal with effectively and quickly I'm
gonna pass over to do Ivan but you know
obviously you know lots of people are
saying well you know what's the message
to the to the people of Leicester and by
message you know very clearly is you
know stick together stay strong stay
safe and for the time being stay home